new at 6 30 a comment made
at a board of regents meeting is drawing
a lot of heat tonight
thank you for joining us at 6 30 on this
friday evening i'm brian loftis
and i'm kirsten joyce listen into what
occurred
i'm going to ask you to please mute
yourself
i don't want a man speak but i will have
to if you continue your child speak so
please stop
now governor siselek responded to the
video and demanded a swift apology to
regent lisa levine who the comment was
directed to
as for levine she responded by saying
quote it wasn't just
me who was shut down it was every victim
and survivor of sexual violence whose
voice should have been heard and who i
was fighting for let us not be
discouraged but keep going
from nevada attorney general aaron ford
quote this is utterly ridiculous
shame on dean gould for disrespecting
regent lisa levine like this
and interesting to note the disrespect
occurred during a meeting that discussed
sex discrimination under title ix
sure hope the nshe board of regents
addresses this nonsense
end quote we will have more on this
coming up tonight
at 11 brian